the restaurant whose owner asked the
president's press secretary to leave
over the weekend will remain closed for
several more days that owner has also
now just resigned from a local business
organization there meanwhile many in the
small northern virginia community feared
their business may now suffer
correspondent Doug mackelway is in
Lexington again tonight Stonewall
Jackson and Robert idli are both buried
in Lexington Virginia reminders that
some civil wars are not as soft as the
one Lexington is experiencing today
numerous shop owners refused to talk to
us about the Red Hen controversy worried
that if you take aside you risk
alienating half your customers for me
what's happening in this country the
mean is not happy were those mouths and
often either side just talking to the
people that supported this woman what
she did is really embarrassment to all
of us the red hens owner Stephanie
Wilkinson was also until today the
executive chair of an influential
business group here Main Street
Lexington she resigned from that post
this afternoon according to published
reports after Sarah and her husband left
and the family relocated to a restaurant
across the street the owner of the Red
Hen then organized an effort to go and
scream at them from the sidewalk at the
other restaurant
Huckabee's story confirmed by the man
who hosted the Sanders family at his
bed-and-breakfast
it's just an unfortunate situation
you know because I guess again if you're
trying to make a statement you know make
the statement
don't keep screaming it you know and
follow people were or what happened 200
miles to the north a congressman who was
nearly killed by gunmen with extremist
views knows how far such incivility can
go I know firsthand we've got to be real
careful about how we discuss our
differences the great part of America is
that we can discuss our differences
freely and openly but we also have a
responsibility to make sure that we're
not trying to incite others to violence
more Democrats are joining Senate
Minority Leader Schumer's call for
civility a spokesman for Virginia
Democratic senator Tim Kaine told the
Richmond times-dispatch that he quote
believes in civility and respect from
everyone are important to a functioning
democracy we're told that the red hen
restaurant which had been scheduled to
reopen at 5 o'clock this afternoon will
now remain closed until July 5th and for
the first time as you can see we are
seeing protests here today they're
winding down right now only one arrest
thus far a Donald Trump supporter threw
a bucket of chicken manure in the
direction of the building he was
promptly arrested Brett Tuggle mackelway
in lexington virginia Doug thanks